je pense que quand on est amis avec toi
il y a beaucoup de gens qui aiment pas
ah ouais donc le Garde des Sceaux est
puissant
il a pas très bien pris ce qui a été dit
sur lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reportage sont les petites combines ce
qu'ils ont appelé les petites combines
des forains pour gagner de l'argent
notamment au jeu de la pince vous avez
déjà tous Voilà faire le jeu de lapin
regarde avec cette manette il faut
diriger le crochet pour attraper des
peluches et autres cadeaux
au niveau en fait de la technique
c'est-à-dire que en fait en travaillant
sur sur les réglages je peux dire à la
machine voilà tu gagnes tout le temps
par contre je peux lui dire voilà tu
gagnes à 1 sur 1 tu gagnes un sur deux
je gagne un sur trois ou un sur 25 vous
aurez beau vous acharnez rien n'y
changera la force de la pince est réglée
à l'avance c'est comme au casino arrêter
tu mets 1 € au casino tu gagnes pas un
million d'euros je veux dire c'est ils
sont dans un monde les gens de pouvoir
croire à sa règlement
c'est la loi tu vas pas pour gagner de
l'argent
veut pas dire Mathieu ce qu'on est en
train de dire c'est que au casino aussi
ils savent un peu qui va gagner parce
que c'est un moment la machine va donner
oui moi j'ai pas du tout aimé ce
reportage qui était clairement à charge
en fait on fait passer les forains pour
des arnaqueurs pour des gens malhonnêtes
qui respectent aucune loi qui emploie
des enfants enfin la manière dont tout
était raconté c'était horrible d'abord
ils sont très riches d'abord
avec un reportage on peut tordre la
réalité dans un sens ou dans un autre
moi j'ai vu des gens hyper soudés qui
roulent pas forcément sur l'or et pardon
mais le truc de lapin c'est nul mais il
faut penser il t'attendais ça un
commerce il y a l'emplacement il y a
l'électricité le mec qui vient il est
pas gratuit il faut comprendre ça tu
payes tout oui mais c'est les gens
jouent ils ont envie de gagner un paquet
de chips à 4,50 € de quoi tu me parles
il est comme ça le paquet de chips en
vérité quand tu vas la fête foraine tu
dis voilà je vais dépenser ton je vais
faire telle attraction mais qui va pour
le kit si tu vas à la fête foraine pour
te dire je vais devenir millionnaire je
vais gagner toutes les pièces qui vont
tomber ou je vais gagner un iPhone ou
une bonne voiture non je suis désolé
voilà c'est c'est donc en fait c'est
c'est des trucs ça juste pour [ __ ] les
gens dans la merde voilà je pense que
les gens dans la merde moi je suis
d'accord avec vous le stigmatiser les
gens du voyage mais ensuite là où je ne
suis plus d'accord c'est que mon cher
Enoch c'est quand même une gigantesque
arnaque les carabines sont truqués on
apprend que quand on tire la carabine
c'est truqué la grue la machine à pince
c'est fait pour que les gens perdent
donc une autre ils ont quand même une
organisation pour arnaquer les gens
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau mais c'est
pas nouveau
ça veut dire que le mot égo là là tu
prends un exemple c'est comme si vous
savez quoi c'est comme s'il y avait un
mur blanc de 10 mètres et tu as un point
noir et tu vois que le point noir mon
frère c'est parce que 1 et de la vie on
dirait que tout le monde vous savez ce
qui m'énerve c'est sur un fond de
racisme je vais vous expliquer non
attendez non mais c'est normal tu es
blonde yeux bleus mon vin tu sais pas ce
que c'est facile on va t'en fraîcheur
si c'est parce que c'est des gitans pour
faire au quotidien moi je le sais mes
enfants vont à l'école tu sais ce que
c'est d'être gitan aujourd'hui il y a
pas d'association pour nous protéger il
y a rien c'est-à-dire qu'il y a rien
pour les gitans aujourd'hui tu peux dire
tu peux mettre un panneau à l'entrée
d'une vie d'une ville interdit aux gens
du voyage fais-le pour les feuilles
fais-le pour les sexuel c'est le pour
les musulmans mais la ville elle coule
mais aujourd'hui en France tu peux ça
veut dire le Gitan tu peux tout dire sur
lui ça passe crème et moi un autre jeu
qui cartonne dans les fêtes foraines
c'est le tir à la carabine tout le monde
est persuadé qu'on peut faire craquer le
fil mais comme il a dit île il ne cède
jamais regarde pourquoi une majorité de
tireurs sur huile sans pouvoir rompre la
fameuse ficelle avec vos talents à la
carabine ça nous arrive parfois d'aller
à la fête foraine au stand de tir pour
gagner des peluches au risque de de
trahir un secret qui est bien gardé les
carabines sont déréglées et permet pas
au pont tirant de tirer correctement
alors lui il est très bon dans son
domaine mais à mon avis il a pas fait
toutes les fêtes foraines le mec
attendez on le croit sur parole quoi on
a dit c'est vrai ils sont en fait parce
que c'est des forains ils ne respectent
pas le fait que c'est un business mais
ils veulent quoi en fait qu'on gagne un
iPhone à chaque fois en dépensant 1 euro
c'est pas compris il y a un mec qui
disait le reportage qui l'a payé son
manège 600000 euros faut en vendre des
tickets pour rentabiliser le serveur
il gagne 1000 euros par mois donc faut
arrêter il est décrédibilise parce que
c'est la même chose sur toutes les
entreprises toutes les entreprises
doivent faire du bénéfice mode couper la
parole mais si tu leur dis si tu leur
dis les gitans sont gentils ça va bien
ma chaîne personne là regarde l'émission
mon frère alors je veux pas défendre
même si mais si tu leur dis tout le
monde est gentil tout le monde il est
beau bien sûr tu zappes sur les mariages
incroyable mariage
[Musique]
notre histoire commence le 29 août
dernier lorsque l'on découvre ces images
choquantes enregistrées par une caméra
de surveillance à Cannes on y voit une
femme de 89 ans en train de se faire
violemment agresser par trois jeunes
âgés de 14 à 15 ans montant du vol
seulement 10 euros maire de Cannes David
Linard réagit 3 jours plus tard s'il
s'agissait de ma mère qui avait été
ainsi agressé c'est peut-être moi qui
serait aujourd'hui en prison déjà
première question comment elle va votre
maman
c'est à dire elle va comment elle est là
elle est sortie aujourd'hui elle est
avec ma sœur en bas qui s'occupe d'elle
ses petits-enfants quand même qui
s'occupent d'elle parce que moi je suis
dans le Var et aller à l'étambins donc
si beaucoup ma nièce justement qui va
arriver qui va arriver qui s'occupe bien
de ses papiers et tout et qui a eu qui a
eu un rapport avec la police et tout
quand ça s'est passé comment comment
vous l'avez appris moi je l'ai appris
parce que ma sœur m'a téléphoné en me
disant maman s'est fait agresser et
quand j'ai vu la photo
pas possible ils auraient pu prendre le
sac à main sans la frapper vous avez la
violence du cookies le mec dessus mais
c'est pas avoir des couilles des trucs
comme ça et l'autre il filme il filme il
filme les conneries qui font et vous
voulez pas avoir la haine vous que si je
l'ai devant le mec je l'ai tue tous les
trois moi je dis la même chose que vous
mais je vous le dis qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent pour bouger ils ont 14 15 ans
mais attends il apprennent un
responsabilité de tuer une personne bien
sûr mais quand ils en arrivent à faire
des actes comme ça pour moi pour moi il
n'y a pas de il y a pas d'excuses il y a
pas d'excuses alors il paraît que la
famille j'en ai fait dans ma vie des
conneries moi mais des trucs comme ça
jamais je suis tellement
je suis tellement fâché à l'intérieur
des trucs
pas moi je m'appelle en direct David qui
est là qui m'appelle on dirait qu'il
doit nous regarder ça c'est bonsoir
bonsoir David bonjour Cyril ça va bien
David vous devez nous regarder nous
sommes en direct
[Musique]
c'est évidemment et je confirme je
l'assume calmement
[Musique]
violence et de la loi du Taillon
personnel
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui tu es tu as plus de
964 sur snapchat et plus de 538 sur
insta voilà plus les personnes me
suivaient plus le harcèlement s'empirer
ça a vraiment commencé le vrai
harcèlement je pars du harcèlement
dangereux à la naissance de ma fille
c'est Anna donc c'est mon rôle de mère
qui a directement été pointé parce que
voilà être maman à 19 ans etc enfin
c'est comment aujourd'hui mais une maman
qui expose ça tôt etc on va vite la
juger on va tout remettre sur l'âge etc
et c'est à ce moment là que vraiment le
harcèlement il a été intense
je me réveille le matin je prends mon
téléphone voilà c'est naturel quoi
vraiment c'est devenu pour vous c'est
c'est un mode de vie
donc le matin vous votre téléphone c'est
votre travail exactement du coup oui
plein d'autres choses des péripéties qui
peuvent arriver à plein de gens comme
des cambriolages des choses comme ça en
fait à chaque fois qu'il m'arrive
quelque chose je le fil ça veut dire que
je vais acheter du pain je vais le
filmer je vais marcher je vais dire que
je marche enfin voilà quoi c'est naturel
quoi
je pense la chose qui a été le plus dur
dans mon harcèlement ça a été le fait
qu'on me ramène les assistantes sociales
chez moi pour remettre en cause
l'éducation de ma fille que j'aime et
que j'embrasse j'aime plus que tout
c'est sympa ok ils vous ont dit à
travers quoi à travers les vidéos que
vous montez voilà exactement ils ont
pris des vidéos hors contexte par
exemple une vidéo où je suis dans la
piscine je filme ma fille elle est
également dans la piscine mais il y a
personne autour du cadre de ma fille
elle embrassard etc et elle dit que il y
a personne dans la piscine pour
surveiller la petite mais moi je la file
enfin la petite donc je suis dans la
piscine aussi cambriolage aussi
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
en fait j'étais au Maldives avec avec
mon mari et quand vous filmiez vous
étiez au Maldives en fait ils sont
montés chez moi j'habite j'habitais dans
un immeuble au 4e étage et ils sont fait
passer pour EDF aller vraiment prévenir
les voisins qui auraient des travaux ils
ont cassé la porte et voilà et c'est
vrai c'est la vidéo qu'on voit ici
[Musique]
rien mon bébé tu m'as pas vu ça tu as eu
peur et puis ils ont laissé ça sur le
lit c'est pour ça qu'elle allait avoir
l'argent regardez ça de la porte
voilà l'état de la porte et c'est rigolo
alors il y a plein de gens qui disent
aussi c'est peut-être je viens de te
faire cambrioler tu vas mettre ça sur
les sur les réseaux c'est le réflexe que
tu as tout de suite je contrôle pas trop
mes émotions moi je suis parfois je
regrette ce que je mets je vais jamais
dire que j'ai jamais rien regretté
malheureusement tout ce que je dis
aujourd'hui ça prend tellement des
proportions que même si je regrette au
bout de 5 minutes ça y est c'est déjà
partout en fait donc il y a plein de
choses ça je le regrette pas c'était mes
émotions ça m'a fait du bien de partager
ça j'ai eu des témoignages de personnes
qui se sont fait cambrioler etc un
cambriolage c'est pas apprendre à la
légère c'est un traumatisme c'est un
c'est excusez-moi du terme mais c'est
comme un viol un cambriolage on est
rentré chez vous on a vu où vous dormez
on a vu où vous l'avez etc donc ouais
aujourd'hui je m'empêche de partager
plein d'autres choses que j'aimerais
directement dire etc mais en fait elle
met tellement des bâtons dans les roues
sur plein de choses que par exemple je
vais aller au resto elles vont annuler
ma réservation du resto si je vais dire
les filles je vais manger un restaurant
on voit la Tour Eiffel elles vont savoir
enfin elles vont taper les restos de
Tour Eiffel elles appellent l'autre fois
j'ai été avec mon mari et elles avaient
annulé la réservation je suis arrivée et
je me suis plantée n'oubliez pas de
réservation ton mari il en a pas marqué
sur tout le temps sur ton tel
et on peut plus
comment tu peux ça comment tu peux
montrer ton enfant comme ça à
l'intelligent sans son accord c'est à
dire que peut-être que plus tard cette
fille-là va avoir des problèmes sans son
accord alors en fait déjà ça je vais pas
dire ça a été malgré moi parce que ça a
été un choix mais c'est un an à chaque
fois que je sortais dans la rue on
essaie de me voler des photos c'était un
vivable je la cachais je la mettais
sous-découvertures et cetera ça c'est le
premier point dans tous les cas elle
aurait fuité comme mon fils a fuité je
marchais à l'aéroport il y a pas
longtemps on apprend en photo mon fils à
mon insu on l'a publié
vraiment tu la mets comme ça
non le marketing de la famille ma fille
absolument pas non pas du tout elle est
très aimée elle est enfin voilà ça a été
une continuité pour moi elles m'ont vu
marier elles m'ont vu mettre au monde
cet enfant et la montrer en fait ça a
été un peu malgré moi mais mon choix il
a été influencé par ma communauté oui je
voulais leur montrer ma fille
aujourd'hui
tu peux plus revenir en arrière c'est où
tu te dis stop et en fait j'arrête tout
et je vais aller travailler un travail
je vais aller trouver un travail je sais
pas un autre travail normal j'ai envie
de dire entre guillemets ou bien je suis
obligé
harcèlement en fait moi hashtag il a
tellement pris tes proportions que je
comprends pas les milliers de mails que
j'ai envoyé à Twitter qui disait rien
fait pour ça on croirait que ça les
amuse de voir la publicité sur un
hashtag qui prône le harcèlement toute
la journée
enfin je sais pas c'est pas un tweet
c'est pas deux c'est tous les jours
depuis deux ans et demi c'est vraiment
un pesant c'est faut le vivre pour le
comprendre et peu importe ce qu'il y a
derrière dans tout le cas personne ne
mérite d'être harcelé d'être moindre
fait chez elle et alors toi tu le joues
aussi parce que tu as dit tu montres ta
vie donc voilà c'est en fait c'est le
oui comme je disais tout à l'heure au
niveau des critiques et tout ça c'est
totalement normal tu prends ce cet
aspect des réseaux sociaux tu prends
aussi les critiques et tout ce qu'il y a
derrière mais mettre en danger les
enfants etc ça c'est quelque chose que
il y a même pas que ça il y a les
secrets professionnels qui est pas
respecté à la sécurité sociale
j'accouche on le met des règles on le
met direct sur Twitter le nom de mes
enfants etc alors je l'ai même pas
encore annoncé ce que tu es heureuse
aujourd'hui
oui mais oui mais pas ouf je pourrais
l'être encore plus qu'est-ce qui ferait
que tu sois encore plus on me laisse
tranquille en fait tu m'aimes pas tu me
suis pas et puis voilà j'ai même pas
tout simplement pas qui
souhaitent faire du mal faire du mal
vraiment elles font elles font des gros
problèmes elles envoient des messages à
mon mari et elle vont très loin elles
vont très loin très très loin ça dissout
les liens familiaux etc c'est c'est
au-delà des réseaux sociaux là
[Musique]
promotion de son ouvrage La Cavale mais
sur notre plateau Marco mollis est aussi
laissé aller à quelques confessions de
réussir à passer avec des passeports qui
ne me ressemblent pas ça veut dire qu'en
vérité c'est le Moulin Rouge des
confessions qui lui valent aujourd'hui
d'être rattrapés par la justice ou Marco
nous racontait sa cabane nous raconter
et notamment tu peux peut-être nous re
raconter
tu avais fait des faux papiers ouais
enfin j'avais pas fait de moi j'avais
fait des faux papiers c'est ce que tu
dis dans les mais j'avais aussi pris des
papiers des papiers les autres d'accord
pas de sport des autres donc parce que
tu étais en cavale comment tu aurais pu
faire ah oui bah c'est sûr tu vas pas
avec Marco Bouly je suis mort oui donc
j'ai été et puis là je reçois une
convocation faux usage de faux faut pas
pied on me fait une enquête sur 2016 on
est presque en 2023 c'est à dire que
dans mon livre j'ai pas menti parce
qu'il y a la preuve aujourd'hui que la
justice va me faire un peu de bobo à mon
avis c'est que j'ai plutôt une grosse
gueule et qu'ils ont envie que j'arrête
j'ai entendu qu'ils veulent arrêter mon
livre c'est sûr et certain ils veulent
l'arrêter là c'est sûr parce que ça fait
mal à beaucoup de gens je pense que
quand on est amis avec toi il y a
beaucoup de gens qui aiment pas ah ouais
ouais on verra comment ça va se passer
tu sais que c'est le 10 novembre je ne
sais pas comment ça va se passer et je
ne sais pas qui a derrière le problème
c'est qu'on m'a dit qu'il y avait des
gens derrière et je pense que c'est un
peu à cause de toi c'est fou ça pour toi
ouais vraiment ouais parce que tu as
attaqué quelqu'un de t'attaquer
quelqu'un et je pense qu'ils vont faire
son
son cheval de bataille ce qui est vrai
et je comprends l'inquiétude de Monsieur
Mouilly on peut quand même se
questionner sur cette autocésine du
parquet parce que en réalité ce que
Monsieur mouillé a fait c'est qu'il a
raconté une infraction qui est la
commise en 2016 alors d'abord je tiens à
vous rassurer à mon avis il y a quand
même un enjeu procédural parce que 2016
plus 6 on est en 2022 donc il me semble
que les faits sont prescrits donc je
comprends même pas pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez été convoqué parce qu'à mon
sens il y a une prescription ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que il y a une auto saisine du parquet
pour quelque chose qui est quand même
pas gravissime c'est un délit
sincèrement tu m'as plumes comment tu as
parlé et ben je vais te prendre dans
cette affaire tu penses que tu en es
capable on va travailler ensemble non le
mot c'est pas tu en es capable de
travailler non le mot c'est pas là mais
moi je vais pas entendre ça je veux dire
t'inquiète pas tu vas pas en prison
Marco mon lit vous n'allez pas aller en
prison je t'aime mon frère
où vous êtes entre guillemets attaquer
l'émission s'est attaquée aux garde des
sceaux on va dire les noms
moi je vais le dire donc le Garde des
Sceaux est puissant
il a pas très bien pris ce qui a été dit
sur lui c'est quelqu'un qui a une très
haute conception de lui-même il n'avait
déjà pas très bien pris que Monsieur
Darmanin soit votre invité parce
qu'entre les deux
et il a dit ça le lendemain de
l'émission avec Gérald darmann il y a
quelque chose
qu'il a irrité effectivement c'est que
on remette en question sa légitimité ne
supporte pas ça donc
j'ai pas les mêmes sources que vous mais
c'est tout à fait plausible c'est même
très possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors anthony est avec nous merci d'être
avec nous Anthony chauffeur VTC c'était
la première fois que ça vous arrivez
première fois en 5 ans ça fait 5 ans que
vous êtes VTC
tout se passe bien jusqu'à jeudi dernier
le deuxième cours de la journée et puis
[Musique]
elle a voulu me comment dire me au
départ qu'est-ce qui se passe donc vous
allez chercher donc j'arrive elle me dit
qu'elle a qu'un billet de sens c'est une
course à peu près 50 euros d'accord que
je lui donne 50 euros et qu'ensuite elle
me ramène la monnaie j'ai refusé
d'accord oui donc c'est donnez-moi 50
euros je vous ramène 100 tout de suite
donc je suis d'accord mais bon donc en
fait ouais d'accord
donc après il monte quand même dans la
voiture elle était avec eux je vais
chercher l'argent je reviens elle était
toute seule à la base donc elle revient
avec le monsieur et au final ils veulent
pas payer je demande de payer comme
c'est une course en espèces et parce que
là on vous voit rouler oui bah c'est au
moment où je ralentis il voulait pas
payer donc j'ai dit on va on va en
rester là ah oui j'ai j'ai eu peur pour
ma vie donc mon premier réflexe est de
j'ai vu des gens dans la rue d'ouvrir le
carreau et hurler et ça vous avez hurler
d'ici là c'est la meilleure chose à
faire je pense que ça m'a ça je pense
que ça m'a bien sauvé quand même
derrière vous avez porté plainte vous
avez tout de suite j'ai porté plainte et
les individus ont été retrouvés c'est en
cours aujourd'hui quand vous refaites
vous avez repris les courses non non
j'ai pas je compte pas reprendre tout de
suite pour l'instant je me sens pas près
de moi pour l'instant vous êtes
j'essaye de passer à autre chose et je
me sens pas pris dans l'immédia à
reprendre le boulot vous avez été très
choqué parce qu'il s'est passé je suis
franchement je suis traumatisément c'est
pas la première fois qu'ils font ça je
confirme c'est ça vous étiez au courant
oui en fait nous on a su il y a des
personnes qui se sont déclarées aussi
donc c'était le même couple avec des
fois différentes personnes et la
plateforme Bolt n'a jamais pris
l'initiative de les déconnecter donc du
coup là il y a des enquêtes en cours je
peux pas trop parler mais voilà on verra
ce qui va se passer c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils font ça non et
quand on voit ça on se dit que il y a
peut-être tout le système des VTC à
revoir parce qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'agression de chauffeurs de plus en
plus d'agressions de passagers je crois
qu'il y a de moins en moins de
chauffeurs parce que les conditions de
travail se dégradent malheureusement les
gens ne veulent rien payer ni les
chauffeurs ni les courses donc ça crée
des tensions est-ce que c'est pas tout
le modèle des VTC qu'il faut revoir
selon vous moi je vais vous répondre ça
fait des comprenez que justement je
défends secteur on a essayé faire ma
voix clairement ou je vais répondre à
votre question n'a pas eu le temps une
fois quand j'étais venu on paye une TVA
sur les 25% de la commission Aubert
est-ce que c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui
on doit payer à la place du Berg est-ce
que c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui on nous
impose une tarification on nous dit
c'est comme ça vous voulez vous voulez
pas on vous déconnecte du jour au
lendemain on nous dit que ça crée de
l'emploi non ça crée du chômage parce
que je peux vous dire qu'il y a des
personnes qui ont exercé deux trois mois
et qui sont déconnectés à tort et le
pire dans cette histoire là c'est qu'il
y a rien qui va on est dans une société
de où nous surveille parce que dans la
plateforme ce qu'on a découvert c'est
effrayant c'est que bon nous filons à
notre insu on les écoute à notre insulte
nos données personnelles par ailleurs il
y a tout à revoir est-ce que dans ces
cas-là quand vous êtes victime d'une
agression la plateforme pour laquelle
vous travaillez vous indemnise bonne
question c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive j'attends toujours un retour de
leur part à sujet là je peux répondre
non non parce que dans les conditions
d'utilisation générale c'est une
plateforme d'intermédiation c'est pas
une plateforme qui emploie des salariés
des indépendants donc c'est
catégorique voilà au niveau de la
dashcam alors comment ça se passe parce
que vous vous aviez donc cette caméra
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu voir cette
vidéo tournée sur les réseaux vous
l'achetez ça coûte combien il y a
plusieurs modèles la mienne coûte un
petit 200 euros d'accord et à la base je
l'achète pour me mettre en sécurité
d'accord ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui et
aussi pour les accidents de la route
pour me protéger c'est quelqu'un recule
me rentre dedans dans les deux cas côté
client et côté accident routier et je
regrette pas de l'avoir d'avoir investi
et sans les vidéos je pense pas que je
serai là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]